♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A GOOD, WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
IN A LOT OF WAYS, WHAT HAPPEN
LAST NIGHT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
WORSE FOR THIS COUNTRY.
IF OUR CHILDREN, OUR
GRANDCHILDREN, OUR FUTURE.
THE OUTCOME OF OUR PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION WAS SEIZED FROM THE
HANDS OF VOTERS AND NOW RESIDES
IN THE CONTROL OF LAWYERS AND
COURTS AND HIGHLY PARTISAN,
CLEARLY CORRUPTED CITY
BUREAUCRATS.
AND NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS NEXT,
THAT IS A TRAGEDY THEY WILL
NEVER ACCEPT THE RESULTS
OF A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THAT STORY IS STILL UNFOLDING
TONIGHT.
WE’RE GOING TO FOLLOW IT AS
HONESTLY AS WE CAN WHEREVER IT
LEADS.
WILL BEGIN IN JUST A MINUTE.
FIRST, WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE GOOD NEWS, BELIEVE IT OR
NOT, THERE IS SOME GOOD NEWS,
REGARDLESS OF EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT HAS HAPPENED.
HERE IT IS, OF AMERICA REMAINS,
IT IS STILL HERE.
IT’S NOT A FOREGONE CONCLUSION,
WE ALMOST LOST IT.
IT DEMOCRATS TOLD US THEY WANTED
TO BEAT DONALD TRUMP.
THEY SPEND MORE MONEY THAN
ANYONE EVER HAS IN ANY ELECTION
IN HISTORY TO DO THAT.
THERE WAS A LOT MORE GOING ON.
DEMOCRATS DIDN’T HARNESS THE
FULL POWER OF BIG TECH AND THE
BILLIONAIRE CLASS SIMPLY TO MAKE
IT JOE BIDEN PRESIDENT, NO.
BUT THEY REALLY WANTED WAS TOTAL
CONTROL OVER EVERYTHING.
NO MORE DEMOCRACY, NO MORE
DISSENT, PERMANENT OBEDIENCE
FROM THE REST OF US.
THEY CAME SHOCKINGLY CLOSE TO
GETTING THAT.
IF DEMOCRATS HAD WON THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE SENATE LAST
NIGHT, THE COUNTRY AS WE KNOW IT
WOULD’VE ENDED, NOT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BAD IDEAS -- THOUGH THEY
DO, BECAUSE DEMOCRATS PLAN TO
IMPOSE AN ENTIRELY NEW SYSTEM ON
OUR CULTURE, COUNTRY.
WITH NOTHING TO CHECK THEIR
POWER, THE LEFT FULLY INTENDED
TO ELIMINATE THE TRADITIONAL
BALANCES WITHIN GOVERNMENT,
ALONG WITH THE CONSTITUTION AND
THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
WE ARE NOT OVERSEEING THE SPIRIT
JOE BIDEN’S PARTY PLANS TO TURN
OUR HIGHEST COURT INTO A
PARTISAN POLITICAL WEAPON.
THEY ADMITTED THAT.
THEY WROTE MAGAZINE ARTICLES ON
HOW THEY PLAN TO DO IT.
THEY MADE PLANS TO PACK THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED STATES,
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH BY ADDING
NEW STATES OF THE UNION FOR
SENATE STATES.
THEY ADMITTED TO THAT TOO.
THEN THEY PLAN TO PACK THE
ELECTORATE ITSELF, THE ULTIMATE
CORRUPTION IN A DEMOCRACY.
20 MILLION FOREIGN NATIONALS
ADDED TO VOTER ROLLS OVERNIGHT.
THAT WAS THEIR AGENDA.
HOW WOULD ANY OF THAT IMPROVE
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
THEY CLAIM THAT IT WOULD.
MAKING THIS COUNTRY BETTER WAS
NEVER THE POINT.
THE POINT WAS TO CREATE A
PERMANENT DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY, A
ONE-PARTY STATE WITH COMPLETE
CONTROL OF THE POPULATION.
NEVER IN OUR HISTORY HAD ANY
MAINSTREAM POLITICAL PARTY
PROPOSED AN AGENDA MORE RADICAL
THAN THIS.
THEY DIDN’T TALK ABOUT IT MUCH,
THERE’S A REASON FOR THAT, OF
COURSE, THEY DIDN’T WANT TO
SCARE YOU, BUT IT WAS
ENTIRELY -- AND IT CAME REALLY
CLOSE TO HAPPENING.
WE SHOULD ALL BE DEEPLY GRATEFUL
THAT IT DIDN’T.
THEY’RE TELLING YOU THIS,
BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT THE STAKES INVOLVED.
THIS ISN’T A MATTER OF OPINIONS
AND INDIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE
OPINIONS.
AT THIS ISN’T ABOUT POLICY, IT’S
ABOUT THE SYSTEM THAT ALL OF US
LIVE UNDER.